[Musique]
d'accord à ouargla s'est dit si je vous
donnais mon avis mme elles n'embauchent
pas pour moi bah pas cette menace a sa
place ici comme en bouche pour moi je
vais vous dire je vais vous dire la
vérité c'est pour moi et nora est une
des meilleures chroniqueuse qu'on est à
la télé et d'ailleurs on a on a on a
beaucoup et on a essayé beaucoup de
jeunes filles ici et c'est vrai que nora
a toujours été dans le top 2 s et c'est
une des meilleures si ce n'est la
meilleure chroniqueuse en ce moment en
télé et jeux franchement
je pense que chroniqueur c'est un métier
alors il ya eric gil le verrez qui je
dis pas ça parce que vous êtes là vous
étiez un excellent chroniqueur et bhl
est avéré être un très bon animateur
aussi et je voulais dit la dernière fois
dans ça balance à paris je vous trouve
très bon tout seul maintenant moi je
vous dis la réalité pardon moi je pense
que je serai un très mauvais
chroniqueurs et que vous êtes très très
bon bien meilleur que moi je pense le
chroniqueur ça reste c'est un métier est
un métier à l'oeil des chroniqueurs qui
sont très bons voilà et il ya des
animateurs pour moi enora c'est une
excellente chroniqueuse et je pense
qu'on peut faire une énorme carrière de
chroniqueuse et qui n'aura à sa place
dans touche pas à mon poste pendant x
années et pendant plusieurs années et je
pense sincèrement que là où elle est le
mieux et là où s éclater le plus c'est
dans touche pas à mon poste et qu'elle
est très très bien aux chroniqueurs et
je vois pas pourquoi les gens qui ont
des velléités de partir seul de faire
des trucs seul et si s'éclate avec nous
tous les jours pour l'ajout dit la
vérité
pour moi franchement je pense qu'elle
aura doit rester essentiellement dans
tpm paix et que voilà on n'a pas tous
envie de faire des carrières aussi
d'animateurs même franchement mêmes même
au niveau du mental c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup plus dur d'être à la tête des
missions est normal a dit voilà être
chroniqueur je pense que vous vous
amusez vous venez vous venez dire des
conneries autour de la table ou venez
donner votre avis et moi je pense que
nora et est une excellente chroniqueuse
si ce n'est la meilleure et qu'il faut
qu'elle continue son sillon d'antan
chroniqueuse et qu'elle creuse son
sillon en tant qu'aîné chroniqueuse et
je vois pas pourquoi lire et faire des
émissions seul voilà c'est mon avis